you can start out as a bum where you
really can't do it you know and over
time you can actually learn you can get
better there is hope it does happen
Stephen pressfield is back returning for
his second appearance on the show and
all is right with the world the person
that's toiling in obscurity trying to
learn a craft or to you know to to bring
forth whatever it is inside of them I
really do believe the gods watch over
that person Stephen is a prolific writer
and thinker known best for his deep
insights into the creative process and
the psychology of success his books the
war of art do the work and turning pro
have inspired and motivated millions of
readers around the world to embrace
their creative compulsions and the
impact those books have had on my life
on a personal level is just absolutely
incalculable success quote unquote
doesn't manifest immediately it might be
another 20 years before that thing you
know comes to fruition today we
discussed Steven's brand new memoirs
called government cheese I really loved
it and he shares the improbable story of
this amazing life that he's LED where he
goes from this flawed broken truck
driver to fulfilling his dream of
ultimately becoming a writer and of
course we explore the processes required
to birth the creative work and share it
with the world I I know from experience
that that self-doubt is a good sign
that it's you know the bigger the
resistance the bigger the dream he's
just a wonderful humble wise human and I
think you're going to really enjoy this
conversation so pull up a chair and
Let's Get Lost together
[Music]
so nice to see you been looking forward
to this for such a long time
um congrats on the new book
thank you just churning them out it's
unbelievable you are a product of of
your own advice and philosophy walking
the talk
you know part of this really is covet
you know it's like that whole period of
time where you couldn't really do
anything in terms of getting anything
out there so you know I just worked you
know yeah but a lot of people let covid
break them you know a lot of people
descended into you know black holes of
darkness and paralysis yeah I guess so I
mean you know for the The Writer's life
it's not that different from the code
perfect your home in a room my phone
rings a little bit less yeah
um but you know you always say uh you
know it never gets easier like the
resistance is always there no matter how
many books you write no matter how many
times you've gone to battle uh you know
with resistance
um and I think you know obviously this
is a universal thing we all experience
some version of of what you speak about
um but during covet I think you know a
lot of us let resistance get the best of
us you know so maybe there is something
to the number of times you've gone to
battle that you were able to you know
muster the resilience to continue that
battle when it broke all the amateurs
out there maybe but I mean what about
you with your training and stuff Richard
I mean I know that I was reading about
David Goggins the other day that maybe
he even said this on with you that some
mornings he would stare at his running
shoes for 20 minutes before he could
actually make himself put them on I mean
speaking of resistance I mean yeah well
you have to fight it every day right
it's it's
just saying I think that story came up
when you did Rogan's podcast I think he
was sharing oh is that what that David
had had shared that with Joe and uh and
I listened to that and I thought yeah
that's the case there's certainly days
you don't want to lace up and and get
out there I think the difference for me
is is that
um I don't experience a lot of
resistance with training like I like it
like if I have nothing to do like it is
my joy to go out and push my body so I
mean of course there's it's raining and
cold out you don't want to do it Etc and
the resistance will certainly creep up
in those moments but by and large it's
like the highlight of my day it's like
it almost feels indulgent or or selfish
like oh I get to go do this thing so the
resistance in my experience shows up in
other in other areas like you know
writing something you know a little bit
about like yeah you know I think I
shared in the first podcast that we did
together that this you can make a solid
argument that this entire podcast this
decade of podcasting is one colossal you
know example uh you know this this sort
of Monument to resistance that I've
built to uh make me feel better about
not writing another book you know and
that's that's changed a little bit we
can get into that but I guess you know
the point being that resistance varies
and it's different for every single
person and I think people do look at me
as like this athlete but my relationship
with Fitness is not where I that's it's
like I think David is somebody who would
say I hate he always say I hate running
I hate uh you know he does it because it
is a practice of him having to confront
resistance and that's empowering and you
know has allowed him to you know create
this whole life and
um my relationship to that world is a
little bit different because I kind of
find joy in it
and that doesn't mean it's not hard it's
just you know resistance manifests
other places yeah I mean I have found
sort of during covet and post covid that
as much resistance as I have to writing
it's a joy for me too and it's like when
I can get some of the other stuff that
you know we were just talking earlier
about starting a company and that kind
of stuff like that a publishing company
that's the stuff I really hate yeah you
know so I say oh thank God I can have
you know a couple hours and I can just
get in there and just face you know the
blank page or whatever it is right I can
relate to what you're saying rich but
you've been staring at blank pages for a
long time and you know well enough how
to get you have enough experience of
getting to the other side of that that
you know if you just keep your ass in
the chair it's it's gonna work out okay
at some point and there will be some
discomfort but you have enough of those
Blissful moments where the channel is
wide open and the Muse is you know
dancing with you and I'm sure you live
for those moments yeah I do yeah yeah
and they don't always come you know they
don't always come when you when you
summon them though right no it's you
know it's the same thing of grinding it
out you know and making yourself making
it happen you know through action
well it was really great
um reading government cheese I loved it
uh and I learned so much about your life
I mean I've heard you speak about your
journeyman days and all these you know I
don't 20 some odd jobs that you've had
over the years and I did this and I did
that but this book like holy [__] like
I'm like wow you really did live the
journey in life like I think it was
I mean we're halfway into the book and
you know that that typewriter still
hasn't emerged from the back of the band
I was like when does the writing part
start you know like this was a
hard-fought you know multi-decade
uh thing you know that that that really
I mean for me it's beautifully raw but
it really
um
you know gave me an appreciation of just
how severe the resistance operated in
your own life and everything you kind of
endured and experienced to become this
person who has the authority to talk
about like these issues because you
lived it as much as anybody I'm sure
ever has well yeah I don't know about
that but it certainly was a long hard
slog before
you know I took the typewriter out and
actually sat down and tried to you know
and found that that uh I could do it and
it wouldn't drive me crazy whereas my
first experience of it you know first
trying to write the first book when I
was 23 or whenever it was was a complete
disaster and uh yeah the whole thing
where I thought
Steve you're an absolute idiot for
having tried to do this you know don't
ever think about doing it again
to the moment you know a few years later
when I actually could sit down and even
churning out just garbage just if it
didn't matter you know just the fact of
being able to punch the keys and take a
few pages out of the typewriter at the
end was you know
battery charging to me instead of
battery depleting right so so early in
the book you know we we were made aware
of this typewriter that's hiding
underneath your mattress and then it
really doesn't appear for quite some
time you know and and you know I'm I'm I
don't know how many 150 pages into this
book and I'm like this book should be
called Zen In The Art of a big rig
Trucking the amount of detail in the
world of you know you you have these
experiences in these various subcultures
and and and your depiction of your life
at that time is done with so much
tenderness like so much appreciation for
these characters that you encountered
who you know were very colorful at times
and in many ways like mentors it is a
book about mentorship yeah it's like uh
you know as you know Richard's divided
into seven books and each book is named
after a person and each person was a
mentor to me they were all men for
whatever reason and and very few of them
had anything to do with writing you know
they were you know my boss at this
trucking company that I worked at and a
guy that I picked fruit with in in
Washington and I never even knew his
last name that uh were real role models
to me along the way even though at the
time I wasn't thinking about that at all
right yeah real like most of them pretty
salt of the earth guys so they got the
trucking guy was Hugh what was his name
you right yeah yeah yeah I mean what a
character he was a new assault of the
earth guys and you were how old were you
at that time I think 27 or 28. yeah I
mean the way that the book unfolds it's
it's hard to get a sense of the timeline
because you jump around a lot of your
life and you have so many jobs I'm like
I don't know where I am in this in this
narrative but
um but you really get you know this
sense of all these Adventures that you
want on that obviously like you can't be
a writer unless you've lived your life
right like you're out in the world you
know having all these experiences these
rich experiences man I sort of wonder
how people that you know these kind of
boy wonders or girl Wonders that kind of
come out of YouTube or something like
that these days and produce stuff that's
really good too I wonder how they do it
having you know like coming out of
college and then basically going
straight into whatever it is they're
writing about and and doing a good job I
don't know how they yeah I don't know
how Bob Dylan comes you know to uh
Greenwich Village and immediately starts
writing great stuff you know well that's
an interesting person to explore because
you're the first to say kind of talent
is [__] it's really about process
and work and you know showing up and
meeting the resistance and all of that
but then you know then you have you know
you have the Bob dylans and you have
these people who do do seem touched and
I think you know that makes the rest of
us kind of look at creative Pursuits as
something inaccessible or like not you
know we're not privileged to be able to
you know kind of dance with The Muse in
the way that those people can so we
should just go get normal jobs what I
mean I'd be interested to know what you
think about that rich I mean you think
about somebody like Neil Young
or Bob Dylan or any of those guys that
uh or Joni Mitchell that by the time
they were 20 years old they already had
like a body of work and they were
obviously writing from absolute strength
right they were right in their groove
and they kept going some of them were
still going right
I don't know how does that happen what
do you what do you think I mean did you
watch get back the Beatles I've been
wanting to and I know what is it on
Amazon something I can't access
it's on no it wasn't on Apple Disney I
can't remember I think we actually went
to try to watch it the other day and we
couldn't find it if it's still I'd love
to watch it my point being like you get
this front row seat to this unedited uh
kind of bird's eye view of the greatest
rock band ever that ever to ever do it
while they're just cracking songs in
real time like you're seeing you're
you're bearing witness to
an unadulterated view of the creative
process in real time and it's really
beautiful and magical like when they're
just working out these songs and you're
just like oh my God like this is where
it happened and then you realize how
young they were yeah they're like
because you don't think of them being
like yeah young people who you know the
bit and the band ended when they were
still quite young and you're like how
did they know how to do all of that
stuff at such a young age and maybe
music is different I don't know maybe I
do think there are certain there are
some people who are touched right but I
think
most people who are working in the
creative Pursuits are not you know
anointed Geniuses there are people who
work really hard at their craft
but certainly that certainly was my
experience you know you know if there's
any sort of lesson like as I'm I because
I've been looking back thinking on this
right I've been doing some podcasts and
people ask me questions I have to think
about it and if there's any sort of
lesson that comes out of this for me
it's that you can get better you can
start out as a bum where you really
can't do it you know you're as hard as
you try you just can't do it
and over time you can actually learn and
get better at least in writing it's not
like necessarily being an athlete where
there's a certain sell-by date you know
where you know when you're 75 years old
you're not going to be whatever but you
can get better there is hope it does
happen
yeah I mean not everybody can be LeBron
James or Prince or you know somebody
like that but your book is in and the
Memoir really you know
tells the story of just how you know
long the journey was and what's what's
remarkable like if you have a true
god-given Talent it's your ability to
kind of stay in it you know most people
would have just spun out and ended up in
some other job or career but you kept at
it and writing novels like you know a
year two years to write these novels
that nobody would publish and to
continue to do it I'm like oh my God
this guy's like a glutton for punishment
at some point and I can't imagine the
voice in your mind you know you know
that that that the war that was going on
between like really you're going to
write another novel when you know the
last one nobody wanted to touch uh with
like that's just resistance you got to
keep going are you a writer or are you
not well you know it you know it's it's
really when I think about it too I sort
of wonder how I did it too but each time
I would sort of try to go straight you
know get a real job like like I had
several jobs at ad agencies throughout
this thing because that's a job if
you're a writer you can get that job
right but each time each day at the end
of the day I would be so depressed you
know that I just had to go home and try
to write a chapter half a chapter or
something like that you know I wasn't
living any kind of life like you know
chasing women or anything like that it
was all it was one groove of just trying
not to be so depressed and so ready to
to kill myself you know because of what
I was you know trying to go straight
during the day so I just knew I couldn't
do that it wasn't an option for right
this this is who you are this this has
to be birthed into the world like your
life depends on it yeah true right you
know no plan B sort of type thing you
you may want to have a plan B but they
just don't work you know
yeah it's interesting I mean and you
there's the characters when you're
picking apples who you know these guys
are like I mean they're riding the rail
cars right like these are these are like
you know old like hardcore yeah like
hobo lifestyle yeah train car dudes yeah
and even one of them I can't remember
his name is like you know I tried to you
know I had a I had a girlfriend and I
had a solid job and I did it and he
lasted like 90 days yeah and he's like I
gotta yeah you know like what is like
this this idea that we've been sold
about what it what it means to live a
happy you know fulfilling life in many
ways is a lie and you've had the
experience of being with lots of
different people who have rejected that
and are considered lunatics or you know
kind of outcasts or outliers as a result
of that but there's also
like a lot of wisdom yeah the Mind from
somebody who has the courage to step
outside of that and say I'm gonna live
differently and I don't care what
Society is about that although I'm not
sure how much of a choice it is for
people maybe yeah of course right yeah
you know the when I was there was one
little bit in the book about when I was
at uh living in a halfway house you know
for people coming out of State
institutions and stuff like that and uh
how my sort of conclusion about who they
were because they were really
interesting people I mean we would sit
in the kitchen at night and talk about
all this kind of crazy stuff you know
men and women and uh they were certainly
as smart as anybody I knew and as
interesting as anybody I knew and I saw
my conclusion was that they were people
who
saw conventional life the life of having
a job of settling down of having that
they saw completely through that they
just couldn't do it you know which meant
that they were crazy as far as the world
was concerned the world locked them up
in in institutions but they sort of uh
they and there was no place for them to
go it wasn't like there there was a job
that they would fit into or anything
like that so
but they were you know almost like if
they could have joined an Indian tribe
like Dances with Wolves they would have
done it right and these fruit tramps
were the same kind of guys I mean they
were all alcoholics flat out wino you
know drink till you pass out you know
get up the next morning with no
intention of changing that you know
there was no thought of going to AAA or
this was whatever they were but they
also felt like they they couldn't work a
straight job there just was no way to do
that so they had found this this kind of
crack in the society you know right
picking fruit and riding the rails and
and yeah no one's going to give him a
hard time and tell them they need to
change like they're in kind of uh an
enabling environment yeah for that kind
of yeah life and behavior but it's a
really sad environment and it's and
scary to be in as a like a you know uh
more or less regular person like I was
because it's like guys don't have teeth
yeah eyes your skin I like had the big
medical Pro you know you're hauling this
dude off yeah and he dies and people you
actually found a body in the orchard
yeah but that's real that's apparently
pretty common you know so you could
really see
these guys as wonderful as they were and
as pure as they were in a certain way
that they had a limited lifespan you
knew you know if you came back three
years from now I might not see them
again and they knew it too and they just
you know right there was no plan B and
so what do you mind from that for your
like what do you what do you what can be
learned from that I feel like I'm that
way I feel like artists are that way you
know that
you can't live the normal conventional
life as much as you may want to
um you have a sliver of a skill that you
can do that maybe is marketable if you
can make it marketable but there's no
alt there's no choice right there's no
alternative you're either in that little
lane and make it work or you're going
down you know so and I don't see
anything wrong with that you know I feel
a kinship to those guys and uh
you know the who says that this like uh
that this world that we believe in of
having money in the stock market and
trying to get your kids into Harvard and
who says that's such a great thing
what's so great about that you know
um to get here today you know you got to
drive past these companies you know
these I don't know what they are you
know
um but they're like white collar jobs
right this is West Lake Village around
here it's a prosperous area and I'm as
I'm driving faster I'm thinking I'm sure
you think the same thing Rich if I was
in one of these things I'd kill myself
you know there's no way I could I could
do that so what's so great about that
and of course people that are living
that life they have alcoholism problems
and they're beating their wives or
whatever or or they're just miserable
yeah and that's not to say that there
aren't people who find some level of
happiness in that yeah if you're wired
for that and you do that that's great
like I you know I think you know one
thing we share like you you sort of were
never really part of that you always
danced around the edges of it so that
you could just make enough money to be a
writer whereas I was kind of steeped in
that and had to break free
so I've lived in both of these worlds
yeah a pretty good sense of what they
look like but yes there is you know
there is
there is a falsity in in this sort of
Promise of the American dream and we all
kind of blindly premise our future
happiness upon working towards these
ideals without enough objective
questioning of their veracity I think
and that's not to say that every like
you said like not everyone is born and
bred to be an artist and to pursue that
type of life which is to invite
a certain level of suffering and pain
and risk into your experience that not
all people are you know have the
Constitution for
uh but when you write the war of like
when you write the war of Art and you
talk about resistance I do think we all
have our own unique blueprint and we
have something to say and express that
absolutely ours and there's something
you know I I think there's something
important about everybody exploring that
in themselves and that doesn't mean they
need to quit their jobs and you know go
pick apples to write a book but but I
think it is you know kind of I think a
sense of full Integrity with who you are
is somewhat Reliant upon being in
communication with your own you know
with your own sense of who you are and
and sharing that with the world because
there's only one you right and you talk
about this all the time so uh you know
please share it and don't keep it to
yourself because the more you repress
that I think that leads to all sorts of
dysfunction yeah I mean I'll give you an
example from a friend of mine my friend
Ruthie if she sees this podcast she's
going to be failing you know but uh this
is an example of somebody that has a
calling that doesn't have a definition
to it so my friend Ruthie is uh she's I
don't think she's may have had one or
two jobs in her life but they only
lasted like a couple of months basically
she's been a wife you know and kind of
lived off of whatever husband she's been
married to and uh
um but yet her her role and this is just
sort of unfolded over time
in her family and her extended family
and friends if you're in trouble
you go to her
and she has bailed me out of stuff
many times and I know I can see she does
it for everybody it's like maybe in in a
more of a um uh uh old world culture
there would be the woman that you would
you know that everybody would go to if
you really needed to get your [__]
together and she would help you somehow
and that's her calling but there's no
name for that right there's if you don't
you can't plug that into you know some
specific job and yeah and they don't pay
for it either there's no salary attached
to it but that's her calling and she's
gotten to that so I'm I I refuse to
believe that each individual doesn't
have a call and I think we all do and I
certainly don't mean to say that it has
to be in the Arts or anything like that
it can be and even the people that are
working at these companies around here
I'm sure the ones that are happy
probably have side things that that they
do you know that they're passionate
about and when the weekend comes they're
heading to the mountains or they're
doing something like that you know that
is more in tune with our own soul at
least that's my hope right and and the
the difference the qualitative
difference with Like the quote unquote
art is that they have some kind of like
pain body inside of them that they feel
like they're going to explode unless
they give birth to it yeah like that
would be like life is intolerable unless
this thing is being nourished in some
way yeah and they also have
some sort of a platform or an outlet if
you're a dancer if you're a musician or
something like that where you can
produce an actual product or an
experience that that will let you pay
the rent you know
right but not all you know and that that
can vary right yes definitely so like
you know there's being a movie star and
then there's you know there's doing uh
you know Off-Broadway there's this comes
in all permutations it's not like a
money thing right this is like uh this
is this is like a a yearning that has
nothing to do with like Commerce or
or career yeah right like that's just
you hope it might produce some Commerce
yeah but it's really more about giving
birth to something that's inside you
that won't go away and and like where
does that come like one of the things
that I that I you know I love about you
is that you know you dance with the
mystical like you're not afraid to like
explore the Unseen energies and the and
the vibrations like the very subtle
uh you know kind of wavelengths that you
have to kind of be in communication with
to
be an expressive person
well I mean you know if you're any any
kind of a an artist a musician or
whatever a writer
it becomes very clear to you right away
that what you're producing isn't coming
from you right it's a question of where
do ideas come from right they you know
they songs come completely intact to
certain songwriters right from where
so you you know you I think the
evolution government cheese is really
about the evolution of an of a writer or
of an artist and
there's certain certain things that you
learn here one is the kind of uh the
craft itself you know what is a story
right how does the story start how do
you what's the middle
Etc then they're the kind of soft skills
like
um Having the courage to start something
what do you do when you bog down in the
middle how do you handle rejection you
know how do you how do you uh reinforce
yourself when nobody else is reinforcing
you but then above and beyond that is
the mystical element and is the question
of where do ideas come from where an
idea for a play or an idea for a car
that you're going to build or whatever
it is where does that come from and
where does it I mean the global idea the
big idea and then day to day as a writer
writing a novel let's say where does
scenes come from where do the characters
come from and you've definitely learned
a respect for something that's
unknowable
and you know in the book I talk about
and I've talked about this in the war of
art too I had a mentor named Paul rink
yeah I was I was going to get to him I
mean this is the first you had lots of
mentors but this was really the guy he
was probably the only actual writer
that's kind of sat me down and said this
is what you do kid you know I mean how
many books had you written before you
even understood what a story was or what
a three-act structure was a lot
you could have saved yourself a little
lot time and energy and you know and you
met up here a little bit earlier you
know what it's like you know I've really
learned it all kind of in the movie
business you know bit by painful bit
but I got a lot of questions about that
but go ahead but speaking about Paul my
my mentor I used to uh I I was living on
this little Street in Carmel Valley
Northern California and I had saved
money and I was just sitting uh trying
to finish the first book I'd ever
finished because I crapped out earlier
on you know and Paul lived up the street
and he lived in a little camper at he
parked out in front of his house and I
would have breakfast with him or coffee
with him every morning and he gave me he
typed out the invocation of the muse
from The Odyssey from Homer's Odyssey
from the T.E Lawrence translation
Lawrence of Arabia which I still have
it's like tattered into P it's like
powder but he sort of really introduced
me to the idea that not only the things
are coming from some other dimension but
the people for thousands of years have
been have known about this and have
invoked that other dimension and uh the
Muse and so that really
that was a huge thing to teach a young
writer you know right the respect for
that that has never left me for a minute
right so this guy he's living he's
living in a camper in front of his head
he's got a house but he sleeps in the
camera I mean this guy's a character
right so you know what it is I get it
I'm like he's yeah listen this guy's my
spirit animal
um but he you know provides you with the
reading list you're going to read all
these people all the greats from you
know the the all the all the Greeks but
also you know the Russians and you know
really is a Taskmaster in that regard
and ends up you know providing you with
all these principles that really become
tenants in the other books that you
write the prescriptive books that you
write yeah when you finish a book you
start another one yeah all these sorts
of things that
um become so fundamental like it's
amazing does he
did he ever like I don't know when he
passed or whatever but did did was he
able to kind of appreciate the impact
that he had on you or was there a level
of pride in everything that you
ultimately were able to accomplish it's
a good question because he died before I
had ever had any remote success but I
know that just uh you know we had a
friendship and he was just you know
being a mentor to a young guy that was
trying to learn something but one
interesting thing Rich was that
as he had no respect for writers per se
and he would sort of warn me against you
know like don't turn into that kind of
you know he said you know they're
basically egomaniacs and basically
they'll stab their own you know wife in
the back you know so he said but he did
he was certainly a real believer in
um
in working hard and doing the absolute
best you could with whatever your gift
was you know that this was serious that
you were not just churning out you know
entertainment or something that you were
in you were really trying to to bring
your gift forth whatever it was and he
was absolutely serious about it he only
kind of like lectured me you know yeah
and that it's worthwhile yes right which
a lot of people don't think you know
what Hollywood is you know yeah people
are there you know some of them are
there to do good work but a lot of them
are none
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with them
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
my favorite quote in the whole book
comes from the section about him which
is God's watch over lost souls
particularly when they dream is that
from the invocation I just wrote it down
uh no that's actually that was that was
me that was you I mean that's such a
beautiful
sentiment but I do think it's true yeah
you know that uh
the person that's toiling in obscurity
you know trying to learn a craft or to
you know to to bring forth whatever it
is inside of them I really do believe
that God's looked down and walk and
watch over you you know watch over that
person and uh and and protect them
somehow you know I can't prove it
obviously but I believe it yeah I mean I
believe it I've felt it in my own life
and uh it's a very
tangible experience and I think life you
know irresp you could we could have an
argument is this real is it imagine yeah
but you know I have my experience you
have your experience and I think life
what's your experience no more
interesting when you indulge in this I'm
interviewing you what's your experience
I mean my experience is that is that
when you take those energies seriously
and you respect them
uh that you are
rewarded is the wrong word but
um
you are heard
and you get what you need now
specifically are we talking about
Athletics are we talking about writing
what are we talking about I think you
know I think of it in terms of
of
the pursuit of the authentic self so in
your case that's through writing and
becoming an artist but I think that can
be
you know experienced in many different
ways whether you're trying you're in a
space in your life and you have
aspirations to be this other person or
you have a broader imagination of what
your life could be like but you don't
know how to get from here to there like
how do you navigate that well there's
practical considerations like well I'd
interview for a job or I do you know
these things but I think from
the Unseen kind of spiritual realm
there's a you know that's that's the
lever right that you want to tap into
and I think it's about really connecting
with the truth of who you are and living
as Integris with that as possible and
when you do that I think the universe
sees that and pays attention and little
little sort of bricks on the path are
are put in front of you to gently nudge
you in one direction or the other and if
you are
in a place where you have the presence
of mind the awareness to see that and
heed that then that process compounds
upon itself can you give me like a
specific moment in your in your life
well I mean I think
you know and I told this story in
Finding Ultra like we you know like I
was like I can't be a lawyer anymore and
now I'm like going off and like training
for these races there's no career path
here but I felt certain in my conviction
that this was
necessary as a building block towards a
Different Light even though there was no
logical or rational justification for
that
and I had an aspiration or a dream of
being in a place where I could provide
for my family in a way that was
personally meaningful to me and helpful
to other people and what that looked
like I had no concept of
so it was holding Loosely to that while
also taking actions that honored that
internal voice even if that voice was
orthogonal to you know societal values
or what other people expected of me and
the more you honor that
the more kind of uh
uh
uh how do I say this the the more you
honor that the more likely you are to
find evidence in the world to support
that so like this idea of when the heart
is true the universe will conspire to
hurt you which is sort of my version of
saying God's watch over lost souls
potentially when they drink
and that doesn't mean it's going to
manifest in the manner in which you
choose or on the timeline that you
prefer certainly your timeline you know
probably it was not a preferred route
for yourself uh but in retrospect when
you look back upon your life it all
looks like every little piece was
necessary to yeah
today right there's this incredible
design to the whole thing that when
you're in the midst of it is very
disorienting yeah you're only true north
is that that that like voice within
yourself that you either choose to honor
or you repress yeah and the other aspect
of that is that when you at least this
has been my experience that when you
achieve some sort of a breakthrough on
that path even if it's just a private
breakthrough that it doesn't success
quote unquote doesn't manifest
immediately it might be another 20 years
before that thing you know comes to
fruition so in the movies it's never
like that right you know somebody turns
a corner and all of a sudden
everything's great but in real life it
doesn't seem to so what is an example of
that for you the fact that like war of
art is still like finding new audiences
and exploding like
um you know there's a story that I tell
in a war of art that I repeat in
government cheese about uh a night when
I was
alone in my sublet apartment in uh in
New York where I finally got out the
typewriter sat down and and it worked
you know and I felt like in that moment
okay I'm a writer you know you know I'm
I I knew who I was and I was a million
miles away from actually succeeding if I
ever would succeed but I felt like okay
at least I can do this and it works it
charges my battery it doesn't but yet it
was still another like 25 years right
until I got a book published so so but
still at that point I became a different
person you know something changed in in
My DNA you know uh a certain level of
self-doubt went away at that point and
and if you had to identify specifically
what that was or how that happened and
why that happened in that moment
uh could you describe that I think it
just for me was uh it's it's a really
good question because it's kind of
mysterious it's sort of like
you fail and you fail and you fail and
you fail and you sort of build up ahead
of steam of failure and like finally
it's like you can't fail anymore you
know the gods are going to give you
something that may be a moment where you
know Heaven looked out for Souls that
dream you know where the other dimension
said okay we're going to give it to this
kid you know he's earned it
which I think is true right you sort of
build up and build up and finally the
gods say okay we gotta give this guy
something you know right right and and
your job is to not relent to not quit
yeah if you stay in it and your heart is
true yeah at some point but it's it's
like swimming in the middle of the ocean
it's like what's the choice right you
know well you say like so you you
characterize it or you talk about it or
think about it as this this like
underground river right yeah the price
of of admission to which is the work yes
yeah so your job is to do the work then
you get to Flow In this River and the
river is going to take you where it's
going to take you and there are these
unseen energies and when you're in that
dance with The Muse and you know on a
daily basis and you're consistent in
that regard like something is going to
happen as long as you don't you know
pull out of the river yeah I think that
stop doing the work which is it's a
weird sort of contradiction in that
we're talking about something really
Airy fairy yeah like when I say an
underground river I mean like for uh for
a writer it's the stories that will come
to you right or whatever it is that
you're you're trying to write and that's
that is this underground river that's
inside you but how do you get to it you
don't get to it by mystical means at all
you get to about just busting your ass
every day you know grinding it out you
know through you know day after day
after today of having no inspiration at
all that that that's the price right and
there is a way of getting like the least
sexy or Airy fairy thing ever which is
like the grind yeah and there's no it's
it's an Athletics too right there's no
other currency
other than getting out there on the
trail
and doing your thing right you can do it
smart
but
there's no other currency that heaven is
going to accept yeah
um
one of the things that I think is is
remarkable about you and I and I see
this in in
Ryan holiday also is your ability to
like produce a work and you're you're
already steeped in the next work and
this almost seamless segue from one
thing to the next without like
understanding that to take a break is to
interrupt momentum and momentum is
something to be protected and respected
above all it has its own like force
field and energy about it and you don't
want to interrupt that right so you have
to always be in this sort of
perpetual motion from one thing to the
next which also is about
decoupling the work from the results of
the work right like so it's crazy
you just like government cheese is out
you're doing all these podcasts so hey
let's how's it doing like let's take a
beat now and let's let's you know like
really get into like the results of the
work but I'm sure you're already well
into whatever it is you're writing next
yes I am and I certainly have found that
just through hard experience that the
the worst thing that any artist or
creative person can do is finish one
thing put it out there and then like
wait for the world to respond you know
because either the world is going to
totally ignore it or they're going to
crap all over it right so plus it it
violates some Cosmic law you're not
allowed to
reap the fruit you know you're only
allowed to move on to the next Harvest
whatever it is or the next planting
that's just the the cosmic law yeah and
uh and do you find yourself like is
there Superstition around that too like
have you actually indulge in like oh if
I check that then that's gonna really
this is gonna undercut my exactly
absolutely you know how when you sort of
when you really uh want something and
you sort of check I don't know what like
you check your your email or your
Instagram or something
the act of checking it on some level
prevents the thing from happening you
know right at least that's my you know
it's like when you forget it then you
come home and there's a letter oh here
it is here's a check I was you know but
uh
so yeah I'm very superstitious about
that yeah what are some of the other
superstitions I mean I just do we'll
call them that not obsessive compulsive
behaviors but I'm sort of a belief you
know they uh a believer that uh uh you
know uh things like um like fairies and
elves and and Angels they exist and
they're they're right here right now and
watching us and uh and if we so I don't
want to piss them off you know I want to
show them respect even in my own
thoughts you know because
you know uh I don't know
um did I ever did we ever talk about the
my uh when I was with the Maasai and
they I ever tell you that remember I
can't remember but I'll tell you this
for whatever this is worth
somehow I I had this job and I got to go
to Africa and I got to go to we flew out
to this Mass Eye encampment my
helicopter no roads and when we got
there and uh
uh there was a camp of maybe a thousand
people women kids the whole thing and
the shaman had just decided oh [__] we
got to move to camp and everybody was
just sort of getting set to do that in
order to do that they had to get the
white cattle to lead the other cattle to
the new camp anyway it was a whole
involved thing you know and everybody
had to like pack up all their [__] and
it was all done in the greatest of good
spirits you know nobody was going wow
why do we have to build the camp floor
and they moved the camp like 300 feet
just up the hill that was it boom thanks
okay and I thought to myself I wish I
could have talked to that Shaman because
I would like to ask him what was wrong
with 300 feet down there why did we have
to move and I'm sure he would say
something like you know if we had stayed
there
so and so would have broken his leg I
could see right something like that
would somebody would have miscarried or
something so we had to move there so
I don't know how to
justify this but I believe it yeah I
think
they saw the shaman saw something so I'm
superstitious about that sort of stuff
and uh have you ever read Bob Dylan's
book whatever Chronicles part two or
part one it's very much like that I mean
he's like that he thinks that way too
yeah like I had never thought about uh
how you actually make an album you know
like he like he's got let's say he's got
14 songs he's written him he's got him
on the piano he's got him on the guitar
but then the question is what musicians
am I going to have to do who's going to
produce this should we do it here in La
should we go to Memphis you know and
he's looking for that
mysterious thing you know right who's
the guy that's going to produce it and
the sort of the book is about his kind
of he believes in this this his crazy
sort of we're going here and then we're
going to go to this Honky Tonk we're
going to talk to this guy I never heard
of this guy before he's going to
introduce us to this woman she lives in
you know Biloxi and we're gonna go there
right and somehow it works right you
know it's not it's not something that
that makes sense on paper no but it's
about it's about it's about resonance
and vibration and you know yeah like
there is something about you know the
Unseen enter energies and I think in our
fast-paced modern Western industrialized
World we've you know we've become people
who live predominantly in our minds and
I think we have a certain hubris and
arrogance about our intellectual
capacities where we believe that we can
be all-knowing and our senses are
unlimited but the truth is like our
senses are incredibly limited I think
there's a lot going on that you know our
eyes and ears and taste and smell are
not attuned to be able to notice you
know what's really interesting to me
Rich is now ai I keep reading these
articles right it's capable it's capable
of writing stories sure writing songs
yeah but can there possibly be any soul
to that you know well that's that is a
philosophical question as the AI
continues to sort of uh not just advance
but like like self-learn yeah and
accelerated Pace at some point do we
cross the Rubicon into uh you know
inevitable Consciousness right and yeah
and sentience on some level even if it's
different from our version of it it's
gonna be fascinating sounds like but but
you know the broader point being like
the idea that like if you think about
quantum physics or the idea that like
you know time is a is a is a mental
construct like are we living you know
multiples this is simultaneously or yeah
you know can we explore the Hindu
tradition of past lives and all of that
like whether there's veracity to that or
not like I do think that there is just
so much more happening and we're so
arrogant to believe that we have a grip
on this and I think it's just better to
be in a place of humility and to and to
uh you know acknowledge that kind of
mystery yeah and it makes life more
interesting anyway yeah it's more fun
and you know it's always interesting
when you know the the minds the we know
what we're doing and then like two years
later you realize like they didn't know
what they were doing at all right like
yeah over you know enough time we
realize that so much of our you know
self-avowed intelligence has been proven
to be incorrect so or like the premise
of Blade Runner 2049 or whatever it was
right was that the uh a replicant gave
birth to a to a child right that's not
supposed to happen so that means
these replicants that are manufactured
human beings have us could have a soul
and that's and and that was the whole
case of the movie yes they do have a
soul yeah you know and uh and then we
wonder are we replicants is what
whatever yeah but it's great yeah uh I
mean how do you I mean when you when you
acknowledge
The Muse and these energies that have
shown up for you time and time again
that it becomes impossible to rebut the
notion that they're real and how they
operate in your life you start to think
about
um
you know Universal truths right like
Universal unspoken truths like is there
is there like this is a truth right if
you show up for the work the Muse is
gonna appear for you right like uh I'm
thinking about this because I had
um
Peter Singer here yesterday who's a
moral philosopher kind of a legendary
guy he gets some such amazing people I
mean he was energy in here he was it was
really cool to talk to him and you know
this is a guy who spent his whole life
thinking about these very questions uh
in the construct of of ethics and
morality like and I said to him is there
a universal like does a universal sense
of morality exist independent of The
Human Condition and this is a guy who he
said yes but he's also an atheist which
is confusing to me like how can you
how can you believe in that if you don't
have a sense of
some kind of
spiritual truth that extends what did he
say to comprehend
I don't know if I asked them correctly I
don't it's all like a soup in my mind
but yeah like so when you think about
these energies that you're tapping into
and and your relationship with them is
so real it is real right yeah
so yeah the next question is what does
it all mean right if if you know not
just me but tens of millions of people
out there are also sort of tapping into
energies and coming up with stuff does
that mean that there's a great
Consciousness God whatever who is
moving Humanity in some direction and
wee little drops of water are
contributing to that ocean in one way or
another are we co-creating I never knew
exactly what that meant but is that part
of this deal and then you think to
yourself well what about the guy who
invented not national socialism you know
or you know the evil stuff that's in the
world right that's coming from some
yeah I mean it all goes back to this
same question that you positive which is
like where do ideas come from like where
do they come from right the last time
that we sat down why are they coming
this book government cheese didn't exist
you probably were already writing it on
some level
in your blog you're like you know a year
into it and you're like this is terrible
I should never be writing this like all
the same stuff that an amateur would
think but here we are and it's done and
this is something that that came through
you right and now is a thing in the
world where do ideas come from yeah do
they immensely some you know super
intelligence or you know some godhead
that disperses a collective
Consciousness because I do think there
is something about like on that idea of
of listening to your internal voice like
doing enough inside work where you can
kind of
make sure it's clear skies inside of you
and whatever you're hearing about
yourself is coming through unadulterated
by whatever past traumas or experiences
you've had so you have a clear signal
and I think when you're
tuned into that clear signal there's
something about your kind of antenna
being attuned to the greater
Consciousness like that Consciousness
saying yes this is your role you're
supposed to be doing this and when you
fulfill that role whether it's like your
friend right who is this person who does
so many things for other people yeah she
is in her Dharma and fulfilling that
role and we all have some version of
that role
and what does the world look like when
everybody is
you know attuned with perfect Fidelity
to that signal yeah and the other weird
thing about this rich is that I don't
think there's ever been a time in
history where
this concept had any wide bearing right
if you think about the Middle Ages right
people are just trying to dig a turnip
out of the ground you know or the Roman
Empire Alexander the Great it was all
about conquest and stuff like that right
there never was a time until now I think
when there have been people that have
enough Leisure Time
and enough resource that they can
indulge this kind of top of the Maslow
yeah this is the very peak of the
pyramid for sure right what was I put
here for you never could even think
about no that was indulgent yeah yeah
and also I think the world is basically
breaking down
in my opinion because people can't deal
with that you know we if we want to get
into politics we we probably should do I
think a lot of the the dark energy
that's out there comes from
people on mass who
can feel this that there's something
inside them but can't bring it out or
don't know that it's even possible to do
and so that energy goes into a dark
direction and you know the web feeds
that you know because dark-minded people
can get together I don't know anyway I'm
getting off on it yeah no I mean I I
think I think there's truth to that
listen you know not everybody has
the ability to indulge the very peak of
Maslow's you know yeah pyramid right
yeah
um so it is it is a privilege to be able
to even entertain that we can
acknowledge that and I think there's a
lot of people who are suffering who are
just trying to make ends meet day to day
perhaps they do have some impulse inside
of them but because of the circumstances
of their life it doesn't feel
um plausible for them to pay attention
to that and I think it then festers and
gets more deeply repressed and that
creates a dissonance between the Aspire
itself and you know the day-to-day
existent existence of the the self in
the real world and that has to you know
over time kind of erode the soul right
and it's not surprising that somebody
would would you know
become depressed or resort to some kind
of Darkness yeah I mean you've read Eric
Hoffer is a True Believer in his stuff
I don't know if I have actually you know
who Eric Hopper is that oh this is great
I'll really turned it onto something to
blow your mind Eric Hopper was a
philosopher an American philosopher but
he was a longshoreman and he was this he
I think he was German and Eric Severide
back from the day the newsman back in
the day a contemporary Walker Cronkite
did it like uh like Bill Moyers remember
did that thing with um Joseph Campbell
right about the power Chevron did a
Series with Eric Hoffer where you know
it was multi you know
one-on-one interviews and Eric Hoffer
wrote a series of small books and one of
them was called The True Believer that
was his main thing and his premise was
that mass movements like communism
Nazism and so on and so forth get their
recruits from people in the exact state
of mind that you're talking about now
and of course we can all relate to that
we've all been in places like that where
you know there's something trying to be
born inside them they don't know what it
is that the energy turns dark and
they're looking to some fuhrer
right right that will you know Jim Jones
and Jonestown or whatever the hell that
picture was you know that that that uh
that's where this kind of True Believer
thing comes from the recruits that will
be you know doing this come it comes
from from that yeah it really is Rage
frustration
um and and then you know finding an
outlet in a scapegoat we can I mean this
is this is how National you know the
rise of nationalism and all it's their
fault they're the reason or I don't have
the thing yeah that that I need and a
strong leader to kind of affirm that
sensibility yeah but where this is all
coming from getting back to the concept
of resistance if you'll forgive me for
throwing that back in there is that uh
that
the individual soul
being attacked by its own tendency to to
uh sabotage itself and to prevent itself
from from living out its Destiny
um and being unaware of this nobody has
ever brought this up or taught them or
anything like that inevitably turns down
a darker path and that's where the these
movements come from I know I'm super
oversimplifying it but but we're in this
place now the world is where Freedom Is
Possible
and the top of the Maslow pyramid is
possible for lots of people and it's
called and this is the dark side of that
if you ask me right because if it's
possible and you're not experiencing it
yeah that has to be extra painful if
you're in a if you're in a society or a
situation where it's not possible
perhaps you could find peace yes your
circumstances yes
it's like um
uh datokvi you know talking about
Democracy in America when there's a
society that's theoretically at least of
equals and theoretically free
so that everybody can be whatever they
want to be if somebody else is living
that out and you are not
that's a hell of a reproach right even
if it's unconscious you don't know that
I mean I think this whole I know we're
getting into politics here a little bit
it's kind of like the know-nothing party
you know and the concept of of uh people
saying uh he's no better than me that
son of a [__] you know who's he to tell
me that I should get shots or that I
should vacuum you know whatever it is
that that kind of concept of uh
if he can you know live out his life or
dream and I'm not then something then
that's something it's very hard to live
with yeah and something has to give
somewhere in there anyway
I mean I think that makes a lot of sense
so that's how you know that's how
resistance operates it you know with how
it dances within the political yeah yeah
right yeah um and can you know lead
people down
a path that you know yeah better better
less blazed I guess right
um but if somebody is like let's say
somebody is feeling stuck and they are
in a kind of a you know quote unquote
dead end situation and they're harboring
some aspiration of their for their life
being different or better
um and they can't see the path forward
and they pick up you know the war of art
like what is the
you know the aspiration that you have
for that person I mean I think that
there is regardless of your circumstance
there still exists the ability to change
in a positive way even if incrementally
yeah I absolutely think so I mean I'm
proof of that yeah but um
and I dare say that if we
if you could bring in you know three or
four people and have and sit them down
here who are in that sort of state of
you know seeking something but not being
able to put their finger on it and we
said to them okay answer in 1.2 seconds
what is your dream that you're not doing
they'd know it you know they might be
ashamed to say it or embarrassed to say
it but they'd know it you know and uh
you know and but so then it's nice a
question of well what are you going to
do about that you know is there any
what's the first step to to going there
or what are you willing to risk or
sacrifice yeah and not everybody's
willing to kind of implode their life in
the pursuit of whatever that aspiration
is and that's okay also true right and
of course you you you know you don't
have to blow up your life to do it you
know you can do it in one hour a day
right how did you not end up
uh you know pursuing kind of a a a
Robert McKee you know kind of I'm gonna
do seminars and teach people the war of
art you know career path
I'm sure that must have you know you
must have thought of that at some you're
friends with Robert you were here when
he you know you brought him here to do
the podcast
um it's interesting because you guys
kind of speak to the same things but
you're also really different guys
well you know uh
I've thought about I've you know from
time to time people have said to me you
know you could you're leaving a lot of
money on the table but I would have to
kill myself if I did that you know so I
just you knew yourself well enough it's
just not for me it's not for you not for
me yeah not at all do you write or I
just want to write I want to talk about
some of the Hollywood stuff because the
stories like in the book are insane
uh but but do you look back on you know
either the Hollywood phase or or even
you know all these all these different
jobs that you had I mean there is a you
must have sort of a romantic
relationship with that period of time
even if in the midst of it it was
confusing for you that's true that's
that's very astute Rich it's like
in the midst of it it was hell on Earth
you know but when I look back on it now
that I'm sort of out of it I think it
was probably all of it was probably the
best sort of stuff that could have
happened to me and that uh to knock the
snot out of my nose yeah and to to put
my feet on the ground and to give me
some some role models that I have you
know that I could call on you know
anytime I needed to that's who I want to
be you know that's how the way how would
so-and-so treat this situation so yeah I
do sort of romanticize and I really feel
like if I hadn't had that period of my
life I don't know where I'd be now
um but that that was absolutely
essential way better than four years
that you know whatever Institute right
some some Writing Academy or wherever
where you just were yeah where all of it
was explained to you yeah but do you
look back and think well I could have
saved eight years here and there like I
could have snipped around the corners a
little bit or you are you able to really
of value and appreciate all the you know
all the color and Nuance of those I
value every minute of it and I really
don't think I could have accelerated it
at any it wasn't like there was any hack
that I could have done or anything I
could have leapfrogged you know like the
Hollywood period right you know I I
learned a lot you know in the sort of
the School of Hard Knocks you learned
this you'll learn this you learn this
and if you didn't learn them you
wouldn't have them you know yeah well
the fork in the road there is you know I
could see an alternate reality where you
did stay there or you worked it out with
your agent or whatever you found a way
to make peace with writing screenplays
because you were having success and by
all indications had you hung in
in that world you know who knows what
would have happened but I have no doubt
that you would have become a prominent
you know you know well-produced
screenplay writer you know in this town
you you end up making this other
decision that you explain you know
liberally in the in the book but do you
ever think like I wonder what would have
happened if I no I don't you don't right
because again it's sort of you know I'm
just thinking of this right now just as
we're talking
what happened
was the idea for the legend of bag of
ants came to me
as a book not as a not as a screenplay
so and it just came here just like
talking about the Muse there was the
whole thing you know and
and I knew or I I wasn't no I didn't
really understand this at the moment but
the fact that it was a book
inevitably my agent was gonna fire me
because he'd work too hard you know he
can't he can't come off and do that
right
so again it was sort of other forces you
know mysterious forces
that intervened like I had no choice I
mean this this idea came I was just
seized by it it seemed to me completely
uncommercial I had no thought like oh
I'm gonna it was great you know right I
thought this is the dumbest idea I've
ever had who's gonna want you know but I
just had to do it so I didn't really
have have a choice and I'm glad you know
I'm glad I I got out of that world right
well it is interesting that the thing
that everybody told you not to do that
was the least commercial thing you could
possibly do and was effectively career
suicide in Hollywood was the one thing
that kind of worked and gave you this
new life and not only that it became a
movie yeah it becomes this movie right
and there's not a good movie but like
Matt Damon was in the movie yeah
um uh that's so kind of ironic and and
the compunction that you had like the
clarity of like I don't care this is
right I'm doing this I'm willing to have
my agent fire me and all these
repercussions are of no matter because I
am you know I am in communion with the
Muse and this is this is this is what
has to be like yeah and that is that's
earned right like that's earned over the
many years of being in the process and
understanding you know what made you
tick and what was important to you and
what your values were yeah like you
can't that doesn't come in you know some
seminar or you know no some writing
program that's through life and the
other thing Rich was that the legend of
bag of ants the book at least was
qualitatively different than anything I
had done before and even though I had
done some good things screenplays that
never got produced you know but where
but you know if you read them you say oh
you're good you know
um but this that book was qualitatively
different and and I can't even really
describe it other than to say it was
really coming from me
you know it wasn't me doing a genre you
know let's do a western let's do a
detective story it was coming straight
for me and everything since then has
been straight for me too right so
something changed some Tumblr
clicked over there and I can only say it
happened on another dimension of reality
and then the word you know the telegram
came down to me it had nothing to do
with any decision I made or anything I
did right which then goes back to the
original question where do ideas come
from yeah I mean you did you were a
caddy when you were a kid and so you
have this experience in the world of
golf
um but the merging of of golf and the
bhagavad-gita and then like you know
Gates of Fire like these other books
that you've written
um
like the original notion for them the
Inception Point like that's where the
mystery resides right because you don't
you can't locate that yeah the other
side of the mystery is at least is that
uh
for my career for what I've the things
I've done
each book is a surprise to me you know
it's like you know the assignment comes
down I get the envelope from The Muse
and I open up about that you know yeah
and how does that like when you wake up
in the morning and or after you know
like it just it just arrives like what
is the experience of that for you like
how do you know
um well let's say the the idea for Gates
of Fire the book about the Battle of
thermopoly which was the second book
after bagger Branch so I write this one
book that's this crazy sort of golf sort
of how do you follow that am I going to
write another you know and but yet once
you have one book you know they want you
to do another one so I was just
you know casting about for what to do
and I happen to be reading Herodotus you
know and I got to that part where
they're talking about the Spartans at
Thermopylae and there was a section in
there and it just was like uh the
Thunderbolt type of thing where I
thought this is it
and I thought I thought you know I can
write this there's a story here and I
can write it and here's here's the sort
of handle but but that was nothing I had
ever prepared for it wasn't like hmm I
was a classical scholar it wasn't like I
I ever thought of doing anything
historical I never thought of that but
once it was sort of there on the table I
thought this I've got to do it this is
the thing it's again it's a mystery why
it's but I do believe there's must be
some sort of law to that that
when something real lands on your plate
it's a surprise
otherwise there's something wrong I
think you know be interesting to hear
what Bruce Springsteen or Bob Dylan
would say about because so so much of
their stuff seems like
part of a of an overall theme you know
yeah but I would bet they would I would
bet Bruce Springsteen would say you know
Tom Joad was completely different from
whatever came before that you know even
though it might look like it's not right
and and of course they would all say
that in their
Peak creative moments that there is an
effortlessness to it that it's flowing
through them that you know the the body
and the mind acts as a channel right and
your job is to just you know let it let
it flow out and the source of which you
know is that's what resides in the
mystical unknown right and and when this
thing lands on your on your plate boom
here it is it's your job to run with
that but if you don't
what are you saying to the what are you
saying to the universe what are you
saying about the Muse right yeah and
then and there's a price what's the cost
of that yeah yeah I think you get sick
you know something happens to you
something bad happens there's that
there's a there's a dissonance like
you're not living in Integrity with yeah
that
that like yeah and it's not like for me
at least it's not like it just flows
immediately it's still an incredible
grind and an incredible hell that you
have to go through to do it but but
there is that
sense of uh of blessedness in there
somewhere that doesn't go away have you
read uh Elizabeth Gilbert's book big
magic I have it but I and I know what
it's about I have not read it yeah I
don't but I've written I've listened to
all her other stuff and I'm in a lead
agreement yeah you should big magic is
like you know a compendium to the war of
art I mean her notion is
I mean it's back to that idea of the
collective you know the collective
knowing or the connect of Consciousness
and you know when that impulse to
express something exists like you're
that idea lives up here right and and
you pull it down
and you either express it but if you
don't if you pass
you're like I'm not going to do that
someone else is going to pull it down
like it's out there which is why you
know there's two volcano movies that
come out at the same time or these
things tend to be like there's Trends
you know like oh why is you know these
these two artists who live on the other
side of the planet and don't know each
other both created something that yeah
kind of they they're similar in certain
ways like the idea that there are there
are ideas out there objectively yeah and
back to the antenna like are you are you
receiving that signal
it was that great Elizabeth Gilbert's
story I forget the other female writer
that they became friends and they kissed
and some idea yeah got passed like from
Elizabeth Gilbert had sort of uh uh
started a book and then kind of let it
left it on the Shelf because she had
other things and when she went back to
it it was stale it wouldn't happen and
then after this kiss I forget the other
writer's name so famous really wonderful
female right sounds familiar she wrote
the book and if you want to Pulitzer
prizes right so that's but uh
in my opinion I don't know if I agree
with that maybe yeah she this is you
know I don't know I think I don't think
one person alone that's my well the
expression of the idea is going to be
different contingent on the person but
perhaps the core idea itself you know I
mean how that idea is expressed is
obviously going to be different from
person to person yeah so I don't know
it's all a mystery yeah I mean how are
you you know what is the what is the Pro
for somebody I don't want to assume that
anybody who's listening or watching this
listen to our first conversation so
maybe you know let's explain at hour 113
like what is the war of our like what
are you trying to tell people and how
can somebody who's new to these ideas
um start to think about it you know uh
investing in their own creative
expression
um are you asking me to like talk about
the war of artists well just in general
Strokes so okay you know we're kind of
grounded in the the concept that we're
talking about the concept of uh an
earlier book of Michael the war of art
is that uh there is this negative Force
out there that I call resistance with a
capital R and it equates to
um a voice in our head that tells us
you're no good you can't do this who are
you to think of whatever project that
you have in your mind and also to
distract you let's go to the beach so
let's have another drink let's have an
affair
and the concept is that if you decide
you want to be in the creative arts it's
a war and you're going to have to fight
this Dragon every morning that you wake
up this Dragon of self-sabotage and uh
self-doubt and all that kind of thing
and that to do that you have to find
some kind of a mindset whatever it is
you know a warrior mindset the mindset
of a mother that's going to protect you
know the life growing within her
whatever it is that to overcome that
thing called resistance that it is a war
and you have to fight it every day
and the war never abates never abates
right never gets any less like the idea
that you you had to go to war with it
for this for this book reading that blog
post and all the negative self-talk you
know that you're telling yourself about
this book after all the successes and
the many many books that you've written
like I don't know whether to feel
kinship with you or feel depressed about
that
but it does seem to be a law Rich that
we've talked about this before that um
when you're on to something that's real
that you really should be doing
self-doubt is enormous you know it's
never uh it's never like oh I can't wait
to do this this is so great it's gonna
be so one it's always like oh God why
did I come up with this terrible idea
this uh you know my whatever reputation
happens in me in a toilet what I'm doing
with this one you know whatever so that
that uh that is a thing that must be
overcome that self-doubt and never goes
away
[Music]
um
and I had a lot of self-doubt on you
know on government cheese which is like
stories from my life right I'm thinking
to myself so I'm writing it what do you
everybody wants to read your stupid
stories right everybody's got a million
stories you know you want to tell a
story but when you're picking apples and
Washington who cares about you know it's
like no I think to myself you're an
idiot for doing this everybody's going
to hate it or they won't even tear it
out you know but
I I know from experience that that
self-doubt is a good sign that it's you
know the bigger the resistance the
bigger the dream so as we talked about
before too right so uh so that that kept
me going you know but I know that that
happens in every project and then it'll
be in the future I'll always have to
deal with that and I think everybody has
to deal with it right and and it just
morphs and changes right so when it gets
more new when you're unsuccessful it's
you know who do you think you are when
you become successful it's like you're
gonna ruin everything you've worked hard
to create or they're going to find out
you're an imposter and all of that like
it just it just pivots right and like
why is that why does that exist like
what why is it that that you know we
have to go to war with this thing like
why can't we just be in our expressed
self I'm sure there are people who have
very little resistance I wish I was one
of those I wish there are people who
have very little resistance I can't so
when I've talked about people like that
I go I'm looking at them didn't you tell
me the truth there's no way it's that
easy for you you know but some people do
for some people yeah right and I think
those people when they become successful
that's what we all look to and say well
you know obviously like
this world is reserved for people like
that yeah maybe but did you see the uh
Howard Stern Bruce Springsteen
this thing oh it was really great and
the just really recent I know on HBO or
something like that but even Bruce
Springsteen had a struggle like hell you
know these albums didn't just flow you
know they were they'd do you know months
and months trying to get something right
you know and before they finally got it
together you know so that was very
encouraging yeah it wasn't easy for him
either yeah yeah it's good to see all of
those things
um
uh when you at the very I listen to that
so
um I listened to government she's on
audiobook I had to drive to Fresno and
back on the same day for uh for a
memorial my college passed away
um so I had eight hours in the car so I
listened to it literally over the course
of a day and and at the very end as you
conclude the book when the book's kind
of done then you do a little kind of
Riff like it's not doesn't feel written
or scripted and you're just like I hope
you guys liked it and got like something
out of this but then you you end it like
it I I was tearing up like I just felt
very heartfelt and you said you know I
hope this is instructive and helpful on
your journey you know and you end the
book with this word Journey
and I immediately thought like what
would Robert McKee think about that
because he he has such a problem with
this idea of life being a journey you
you and I would agree with you like I
think life is a journey and I think that
we're all on some you know our you you
can you can look at your life and and
and
lay on top of it that kind of hero's
journey architecture of it and on some
level we're all living a version of that
I think so absolutely yeah and and that
is a journey so like yeah have you had
debates with Robert about this like no I
was kind of surprised when he said that
you know really because I thought that
this I would have said his teachings are
really all about it sure you know so
yeah no I haven't had it what is that
about that I don't know he really
bristles at that yeah yeah I don't know
he's also a Believer I have a
disagreement with him about Talent you
know where he says like Talent is
everything you know and I say child is
[__] you know so I don't know and he
thinks why I'm crazy and I think he's
over yeah no it's great like I I think
like a podcast between the two of you
guys would be like fascinating right
just on like which one of us would lead
it I don't know well I don't know I mean
I just think there's something yeah like
his thing is I do these seminars and all
these yahoos show up and like my job is
to weed them out and disabuse them of
like any kind of you know career Glory
that they're that they're fantasizing
about because it's hard right and you
can't if you're gonna do it you got to
be fully committed and I think you would
agree on the fully committed part yeah
but I think where you you differ is you
have kind of a sweeter sensibility uh
and and a hopefulness and an optimism
that you know we all have something here
to express and we should be it's not
indulgent to to you know go on that
journey of self-exploration and maybe it
doesn't land you in Hollywood writing
screenplays that you sell but that's
beside the point because it's a worthy
it's that is a worthy you know
investment of your time for yourself
yeah that's exactly how I feel so so I
have more I have compassion for the
struggling yeah
that was me forever yeah and he's like
don't waste my time like if you would if
you had shown up in Robert's seminar
which I did multiple times oh you did oh
yeah and he didn't he didn't like sort
of uh make you feel so terrible about
yourself that you were gonna quit and no
because he was giving out such great
information and he was so passionate
about you know like Paul rink my other
Mentor you know the thing about Robert
McKee that's so powerful is that he
really believes in writing you know and
you know he you know a lot of people
might today might say oh it gives a [__]
you know somebody wrote a book from
novel we're never going to read it right
but he believes you know you've got a
gift you got to give it to the world and
you got to give it to an absolutely the
best you can possibly do and not blow it
off in any way and that's very inspiring
he usually he concludes his you know
seminars with that kind of thought you
know like go forth you sons of [__]
you know and and do something good
were you did you go to the seminars when
you were in Hollywood right yeah yeah
yeah so it cost 100 bucks yeah
um they're still pretty cheap at like a
thousand really that's not so bad well
it's done now though four days right
yeah but I think this podcast is going
to go up right around the same time as
uh because we recorded that one with
with Robert a while back yeah these are
going to go up kind of around each other
um which will be interesting yeah it
will be interesting um but during this
period of time in which you're you're a
screenwriter like you have some success
you hook up with this guy you call him
Stanley but what I got out of reading
that part of the book is you also
learned a lot about structure and form
and the idea of like kind of uh mixing
different influences and genres he's
like we're it's gonna be this movie
meets this movie and we're gonna blend
these things to you know together and
we're gonna create something unique out
of that and just like the banging out of
scripts and like kind of um process of
of being a writer like major stronger
writer and perhaps the idea of Bagger
Vance being like the bhagavad-gita and
golf coming together would not have
occurred without you know the kind of
apprenticeship with this guy who you
know yeah I feel like it was a great
apprenticeship where I really learned so
much and uh yeah I have nothing but
gratitude for that for that period Am I
Wrong to think or to say that there's a
part of me that that wishes
uh that that wants to see you kind of
flex
your muscle in the screenplay world like
you because you because I feel like you
you went off and then wrote Bagger Vance
and opted out of that world altogether
right where when you're on the precipice
of like showing the world what you
actually were truly capable of in that
in that world
you're good you don't want to do that no
I'm uh yeah I don't want to do that I
mean in reality like you well know Rich
the only way to really do that is to
become a director to be a writer
director and do it and that was just
beyond what I wanted to even think about
otherwise the writer is always going to
be fired and replaced and you know it's
just in the nature of movie business
what is it that you you want people to
to get out of government cheese I mean I
think I know but like you tell me
um I I
I hope that somebody that's
feels lost and struggling and like when
is this tunnel you know when do I get
out of this tunnel that uh they'll read
government cheese and say
pressfield story is exactly like mine
you know the maybe the you know and uh
it's just it's the hero's journey it's
the process and
you know be patient yeah you know don't
lose heart
um so I hope it's an inspiration
to uh to people a little bit yeah I mean
I I think it I think it certainly is
that I mean I think it really you know
in the tunnel of like how long it you
know how long you were in the tunnel
it's certainly you're like oh my God
like how is this guy still driving a
truck
um it's inspirational in that you know
there were so many instances in which
uh
I feel like a normal person would have
just given up you know and the fact that
you stayed in it even while that
typewriter was hidden for so long it was
lurking you know in the back of your
mind obviously and you know pulling on
your soul and and you know had this
yearning that you couldn't shake and you
know the fact that it took as long as it
took is
is a story about it takes What It Takes
yeah you know yeah
what more could I say yeah it's like
like I said it's like swimming in the
ocean it's like what's the alternative
yeah you stop and you go to the town you
know and and there's no
there's no plan B you're like this is
I'm in you're in it right and so
if anything that might be intimidating
for people though like do you have to be
in it in the way that like Stephen is in
it or was in it or thinks about being in
it but you do right unless you I mean
hopefully most people don't have to pay
the dues as many much as I did but uh
but you do have to learn right if you
were
going to be a brain surgeon or a concert
pianist you would know that you have a
certain apprenticeship ahead of you
certain education you have to have
skills you have to acquire but a lot of
times in the Arts particularly in these
days where you know you can do a sex
tape and you know you're famous you
think oh there's a hack and I'll do that
so
but it's not true you have to you have
to learn
the game you know yeah well it is an
interesting and kind of disorienting
time in that regard because
uh creative products you know con it's
con it's called content boy do I hate
that is is is essentially ephemeral like
it comes and goes yeah and and that
applies to books as well like we're you
know here we get like every like every
new book in the self-help kind of
whatever like it arrives here right yeah
so yeah yeah you get we get after
getting they arrive on my doorstep 20
books a week yeah
and then you never hear you know hear
from these some of them are actually New
York Times bestsellers or they can but
then a week later you don't know you
start to have like I've become
a little cynical about it like just
matter it's so hard to write a book and
these books come and like and I'm
somebody who should care about all these
books and even I'm looking at it like
Okay so this guy's got the answer this
week and I should read this book
um and there's so many you know movies
and television shows coming out all the
time that you can't stay on top of it
and what is worthy of that you know uh
tug on the soul that's gonna be so
painful that's gonna let me give you
grapple with the you know with the
resistance like this but I've got to
have to give you props for Finding Ultra
that was one that was a book that stood
out and will last you know and you know
God bless you for doing it you know that
came out of your soul you know and that
came through hard work and everything
but that's that's a real story that's a
that's a real hero's journey if there
ever was one well and so uh you know I
take my hat off to you for that one yeah
thanks but but then you know that that
was quickly followed by you know the
resistance you know basically doing
push-ups in the dark and now it's like
well you can't write a book like that
again or you already told your story
what else do you have left to say like
all of that kind of stuff right so I'm
doing war with that a little bit at the
moment I think I've I think I have an
idea though I'm not ready to talk about
it publicly but I'm going to share it
with you when we're done here okay great
yeah I can I can tell you right now
before you say a word
that's the idea you should do it yeah
before you say how do you feel by the
look on your face yeah how do you know
because I can see the resistance
radiating off you but I can also see the
dream I can see it you don't have to
tell me the idea I know and I'm and I'm
say this with a thousand percent
certainty do it you know and do it with
the same you know confidence or I hope
you had confidence while you're doing
Finding Ultra but let me ask you this is
it completely different from that yes ah
okay that's a great sign that's what it
should be yeah I can see it right there
it's amazing I'll just tell you what's
going on in my mind your face yeah so in
my mind I'm like
oh [__] like this is being recorded now
if I don't do it I'm gonna really feel
bad and I'm gonna feel like I let Steven
down and I don't want to let Stephen
down then don't let me do it yeah but
don't let yourself down no but this is
great Rich because it's really great for
me to see that you've got that you know
that that flame there that little that
little fetus that's kind of growing you
know if you had a little toenail now
it's you know it's a it's yeah it might
only be two or three cells right
but no it sounds like it's a little
bigger than that to me but uh
yeah actually I I feel excited about
this in a way that I haven't felt in a
long time and I feel like I'm onto
something but the resistance is very
strong and so the only way that I can
do battle with that resistance is to
really lower the stakes as much as
possible and and like Seth godin's been
helpful with this like so it's really
like right now it's really just about
like free form journaling and not being
judgmental about anything to just get to
just build a little bit of momentum so
you know two cells go to four cells or
whatever I think that's exactly I think
momentum is really crucial and important
as we touched on before like I just know
when I have momentum then you're in a
self-perpetuating
situation where the flow comes easier
but if you're stop and start and all of
that yeah it's impossible yeah yeah
well you're trying to respect that I had
the experience you know both in Finding
Ultra and in athletics you know of of
showing up every day and rolling the pee
every day so
you know I think I know how to roll the
pee but I've had a really hard time uh
figuring out what P to roll in the right
in the writing in the writing game and I
took you know it's been 10 years
honestly so and then I can I beat myself
up about that
ah yeah that's resistance too you just
have to sort of just dismiss that I know
um and remember like the the measure of
self-doubt is the measure of how great
the idea is right
so the more self-doubt you have the
better the idea is right the more
resistance is that always true it's
always true it's always true because
it's it's plausible that you have a
really bad idea and that self-doubt is
like yeah you really shouldn't be
looking in your eyes that that's not one
of them yeah this is not this is not
that
yeah no please somebody taught me this
that uh
to start with uh when you're writing
things with the first thought the first
sentence is and the bad version of this
is colon and then start all right that's
that's a good trick yeah yeah yeah and
uh just you know in other words it's
like Seth lowering your expectations
yeah you know it doesn't have to be
brilliant just get something down yeah
and if I can help you in any way
other than reading uh I will I will
count on me as any kind of a resource I
appreciate that you know Seth said the
same thing to me and I feel like
wow like those are the best mentors
anybody could possibly ever dream of you
know to say I'm happy to like
you know give you feedback or whatever
like it's incredible so yeah so again
then it's like well if I don't do this
then that's a massive betrayal of the
Muse I think or you know or you will or
myself you will do it
hahaha
you know it's a dragon
all the all the excuses so this is great
I'm very happy to hear this Rich you
know that there's a it's so great to
have that thing growing in you what a
what's better than that I know but it's
also
you know how hard it's going to be right
and you're like it's hard to run five
iron words
yeah you know
um how do you how do you thank you I
appreciate that
um has your routine remained the same I
know that like you know your physical
fitness routine is really important you
get up really early in the morning and
you kind of have like this is how you do
it and
um is that does that has that evolved at
all or it has evolved yeah you know uh
I I wasn't always doing physical stuff
first thing in the morning and and these
days
um starting this new publishing company
that takes a lot of time even even
though Diana does all the work uh so
I've have to sort of um
find a couple of hours a day like today
I'm not doing any work you know and I'm
dedicating yeah there's other stuff and
Christmas you know but uh
um but I I I do still absolutely believe
you got to keep that momentum going even
if it's only a little bit so it's harder
it's harder for me to find you know this
is the time in the in government cheese
where I talk about when I was working on
that book and I just had I was in this
little house yeah all by myself and I
had nothing I had no girlfriend no radio
no cat though I had a cat but the cat's
quiet you know but I thought to myself
this is hard enough when I have 24 hours
a day what's it going to be like if I
get to a place where I have other things
going on how am I going to focus and so
I'm sort of that's the way the way it's
been since then you know what you do
have a life a little bit of a life
anyway
um you've got a lot of a life but you
can find the time just like finding time
to train you know and that's kind of the
way it is for me I sort of have to I
have to make sure I get it in
each day you know because otherwise no
good you know yeah so so so it's a
consistent metronome of like ten to one
or whatever it is yeah something like
that um do you then like when you're
getting close to the Finish do you go
down the rabbit hole and disappear or go
off to some cat you know some cabin or
hotel room for you know six days
straight or whatever to like take it
across the finish line or you haven't
been able to maintain some kind of
balance I haven't done that but I like
that idea I've heard that do that people
do that you know yeah
because again at the at the end of a
project resistance gets way way way way
bigger so you got to raise your
intensity to combat that so I understand
absolutely going to a cabin or something
like that yeah yeah I don't know I just
I look at
the consistency and the kind of balanced
um equilibrium like Equanimity with
which you do it and I think of Ryan also
in the way that he does it
and I don't know man my life is like
always like you know no matter what I
try to do to like you know kind of
um flatten the curve between the highs
and the lows like I I I'm always like
surfing some kind of insane you know but
I mean when you train like when you go
out to run the trail or whatever it is
consistent right you're on a program or
whatever yeah and you set a goal and
that time is like a sacred time for you
right I mean block everything out right
and you're not you don't have your
iPhone on or anything like that so same
sort of thing right yeah I think I think
it's an interesting conversation around
like structure you create
you have your goal like okay you're
you're writing this book it needs to be
done by this date or you're training for
this race and so you establish a program
and parameters and like I show up every
day and these are the things that I do
to move me towards that goal and those
are very practical real world kind of
considerations in order to achieve the
thing that you've set out to achieve how
does that
um how do you balance that against the
mystical Dancing with The Muse and not
being attached to the outcome and yes I
have a goal but I have to be oh I have
to be in surrender also like I have to
be open
uh and not rigid and how I'm thinking
about all of this like that there is a
tension there right that I think is
delicate and I'm interested in how that
operates for you uh there is attention
but it does work
amazingly enough that you can go into
that office close the door
start to work and very soon
you know good stuff will happen it might
not be like Thunderbolts of inspiration
but you'll be you'll get into a I mean
he must have felt this with Finding
Ultra because it was so good you know
when you're describing you know the race
or you're swimming and you're like you
know blow your brains out because it's
so hard you know can I keep you know
there you were in a flow of some sort
right you're describing your that and
something that happened and so it it the
two things really work absolutely
together the sort of structured aspect
of it and the kind of Otherworldly stuff
um
they they absolutely right they have to
well they have to be in balance with
each other right because any too much of
any of either of those will tip it off
it's yeah I think so right but I would
imagine I'm not a meditator but I would
imagine that uh when you sit to meditate
it's sort of a structured thing right
okay I'm going in this room locking a
door but once you're you get to that
state that then your your mind is empty
or wherever it is and you are in a kind
of another Another Place Another
spiritual mental whatever place
and then when a bell rings you go out
and make dinner yeah
how come you don't meditate
I I consider my writings meditation yeah
you know
I think meditation is qualitatively
different from that ah I do I think you
would get a lot out of uh real
meditation practice yeah maybe I'll do
that someday you're starting to get
sheepish
um
I think you would no I think you would
get I think you would get a lot out of
it I think it
just having awareness of how your
Consciousness operates I think could
also act as
possibly expanding the portal to the to
the unconscious mind or to the could be
to the Muse right could be I don't know
you're not going to commit to that
um what's next what are you working on
now how do you not talk about it are you
like someone is like don't don't talk
yeah don't talk about it I am working on
another thing and what is what is
talk me through the thinking process
around not sharing what you're working
like that like
the sacredness of of protecting it in
that way
it's just bad luck to talk about it
somehow I mean maybe I you know
Hemingways should talk about that right
that the worst thing he can do is to
start telling other people what you're
working on like it sort of lets the air
out of the balloon and I don't know I'm
superstitious yeah now I just feel like
maybe I'm not going to tell you what I'm
working on now
well that jinx it
yeah
okay it'll certainly
I mean it might not derail it but it's
certainly not going to do any good hmm I
don't know what to do with that
I gotta think about that
I'm interested in how
ambition plays into all of this I mean
obviously you know you
you had to have
ambition perhaps an outsized ambition to
kind of weather the many years of
setbacks and kind of not succeeding you
know on the level that you that you felt
like you were capable of
um
how does that
like do you feel
satisfied with your career like when you
write books you're just on to the next
one obviously you want them to do well
but like where does the ambition piece
come in does it derail you are you at
peace with it like do you care about how
the world receives your work or does it
really I do for the work itself
I do but uh but I've almost given up on
it rich you know because it's like you
know
you never know what
work what particular book is going to
get a positive response or what's going
to get into you know
um and uh
uh I really have tried to stop work I
mean you can't help but hope for
something good to happen yeah but
you know like in Hollywood you know you
work on a script you where nothing
happens right you can't say yeah you
know you're so used to uh things going
out there and sinking Without a Trace
that it's just uh if I can just uh have
enough juice left to do the next one and
just keep going and I feel like that's
really all I'm trying to do is just keep
and anything beyond that is just a bonus
yeah it's a bonus yeah and is that part
of the the impetus in in creating this
Publishing Company no that's really more
about um
my books that are about writing the war
of Art and those other ones
can be self-published you know they
don't need a publicist and in fact I
can't even find a publisher they don't
even want them you know so
um
I do want to have a uh
a platform that I can I don't have to
worry about selling it to Harper Collins
or something like that so other books
fiction or anything like that then you
do have to find a real publisher so
that's a problem
so the purpose of it is just for
releasing your own books or yeah just so
much other people's books as well just
my own just your own books and Diana's
you know and how many how many have you
published under your own imprint then
well if we go back to the war of Arts
you know when uh I had a little
publishing company called Black Irish
with my partner Sean Coyne right and I
think I think there was like nine books
or something like that that we did there
and then uh
two on this new one so far government
cheese being the second one yeah
yeah it's interesting in this age of uh
removing The Gatekeepers you know it's
it's empowering for you to own your own
content and control it and when you know
the the majority of people buy their
books on Amazon uh why should you pay a
Publishing House an outsized you know
percentage of the profits on that
um and the other thing rich is that in
all honesty for a lot of these stuff uh
books post-war of art I can't find a
publisher really you know I mean how
many but war of art still sells like
crazy right like yeah people would like
they would like to buy that yeah but
others know you know I think uh this
must be true for other writers I think a
lot of times people think oh you've had
a book or this or that so you can sell
anything not true right right not two at
all you can't even get an agent you know
I mean it's like you know that's crazy
to me that's crazy to me I mean it is I
think you know publishing is going the
way of the movie studios like to get to
get like the you know kind of the
advance and all of that you have to
thread a very fine needle and it has to
be a book that you know hits all these
certain types of marks
um
which makes you know makes more sense
for people to be self-publishing yeah
and I think it's interesting you look at
like David Goggins I think he's the most
successful self-published book of all
time like is that right up there I
believe Michelle Obama like I don't
think so like four million copies of his
first book or something like that
um I mean I don't think anybody
prior to that has ever sold that many
copies of a self-published book which I
think
you know she all the rules around like
the New York Times bestseller list and
you know self-published books being in
bookstores and all of that I feel like
you know his success upends or
challenges a lot of those rules and
probably opens the door for
people like yourself and other people
who are writing great books and doing it
their way to you know have a different
kind of life
maybe I mean I still I still don't
understand the economics of mainstream
publishing how they can make money you
know unless they get one book I think
it's like the one book that supports all
the others I think that's true right one
book
sells 10 million and then they can
afford to have 1500 books that sell
nothing right I guess it would be like
the studio that puts out you know Avatar
the Marvel movies also making like 300
you know movies a year that cost a
million dollars that nobody goes and
sees yeah I guess yeah I don't know
but you can just write your books and
put them out right which has to be cool
um and but my expectations are so low
that's another part of it but here's the
thing so how little you know that really
Stephen listen all this like you know
part of me feels like you need to go to
therapy because like if you're still
having all this negative self-talk with
all the wonderful books that you've put
out and all the you know people that
you've helped and and you know creative
careers that you've helped spawn like I
want you to be telling yourself good
things about your capability yeah and
your skill right yeah but you know how
much is resistance and how much is like
just [__] that you see sales figures
you know well I mean you know it's a
tough racket let me tell you this uh you
know you're
you're the war of Art and turning pro
were so instrumental in my life that
they are that like your work
has you know infused my life and my work
like Finding Ultra is is like you're
part of that book right and you're part
of this podcast like in the collective
Consciousness idea that we were talking
about earlier like your essence is
inextractable from like my career and my
creative life and like the things that
I've put out into the world and I'm
certainly not alone in that regard
there's lots of people who would you
know tell you their version of what I
just shared with you which has to be
incredibly you know affirming right
that's true you can hear them you can
hear you can hear that and like yeah and
so I don't blow that off it's real and
it's huge and it's like a huge honor for
me not to just have you here but to like
have you in my life like that's
something like like talk about likewise
The Mystery of the universe and like
like the idea that one day like I would
get to meet you and I would I could
consider you a friend like that was just
beyond anything I could have ever
imagined and I feel the same way so so
there you have it this is this is yeah
this is you know resistance go [__]
yourself and uh
um you know because we're we're dancing
with the uh mystical energies over here
because it doesn't make sense on paper
and all the decisions that I made you
know when I was toiling away doing my
version of of you driving a truck
there's no sense when you're in that
it's it's there's no sense that that's
leading anywhere absolutely yes other
than some kind of deep down thing like I
got to keep doing this or you know I
know that this is this is somehow and
some weird way gonna lead me to where I
want to go yeah and you stay in it yeah
I just did a blog post like today or
something or a couple days ago that says
something like the hero's journey is
enacted in a be United State
and I think that's absolutely true and
then somehow it's absolutely essential
it's like if you weren't in the United
States you wouldn't be on the hero's
journey it's somehow the the fact that
you that we're in denial
of some truth that and that's what set
us on this hero's journey course or this
period in the wilderness course is
essential that we're in denial so we
can't see it right we're we're a fish in
water and we just don't see it it's like
when you finally can see it then you
come out of it you know or you maybe you
come out of it and then you can see it
finally yeah I don't know why that's
true but I think it is true yeah and and
and in retrospect looking back many
years later you're like of course it's
very clear incredibly clear yeah you
know why it can be more clear why can't
that get that glance be clear you know
looking forward but you know it's not
it's not break it's rigged against that
it's not wired that way right
um which sucks but that's the way it is
right
yeah for some it seems to be a law of
the Universe I don't know why I don't
know man I don't know man well maybe you
know we can round this out with just you
know a few more laws of the universe for
the person who is you know grappling
with resistance or perhaps finds it
finds themselves
you know lost in the Lost in the forest
right now and and and can't see their
way forward because they're not far
enough down the way to have that 2020
Rear View Vision well you know what I
saw actually a great thing I don't know
if you've ever do you ever see um
Anthony Hopkins when he's on Instagram
he has like I love him on Instagram he's
great isn't he I mean he's so authentic
yeah and uh this it was a clip I think
he was on
some talk show or something like that
and then they asked him this exact thing
you know what what what's the word you
because he's the Elder Statesman of
Elder States sure and he said you know
that I wish I could do the accident he
said you know just keep going you know
just keep going keep putting one foot in
front of the other because everything is
going to work out in the end you know
and I thought and it was so authentic
coming from him I said he's absolutely
right that's the again it's like
swimming in the ocean you just got to
keep going because the alternative is
you know you drown so I that that will
be the truth
just keep going there's no there's no uh
there's no plan B yeah all right man I
love it well always good to talk to you
uh I I you know
can't say enough yeah this is great I
appreciate you yeah and the work that
you do and the you know inspiration and
that you share with the world I think
it's like you know it's a true Act of
service well thank you and I'm so happy
to hear that you've got something
percolating that uh is causing you at
night yeah it should be but I'm really
divided on whether I can talk to you
about it now
you know I'm I'm happy in all searches I
I'm happy to talk about it but
I don't need to talk about I don't need
to hear it
I know what I'm willing to share with
you we'll do it yeah okay yeah cool
great deal anytime it's a deal all right
man right now you probably have another
book coming out in another month right
so you can you're always welcome now all
right it'll be a while let's have
breakfast soon too please okay let's do
it but not at that place
we got to find another place thanks
buddy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]